this video is made possible by
brilliance we're going to learn more
about brilliant later in today's video
but if you'd like to get started right
now get a brilliant org /ba graphics
you'll also find a link in the
description below Sir Isaac Newton is
regarded as one of the greatest
scientists who ever lived his
breakthrough idea about motion
influenced every area of physics
allowing other great thinkers to stand
on his shoulders yet Newton was also a
man at odds with his public perception a
secret alchemists and a heretic who
risked his life to write about the
failings of the Anglican Church in
today's by graphics were uncovering the
truth about the real Isaac Newton Isaac
Newton was born on January the 4th 1643
in Woolsthorpe by coast to earth a small
town in the country of Lincolnshire in
England he was a premature baby who was
so small that his mother said that he
would have hid inside a court mug with
room to spare the doctor who delivered
him didn't think that he'd survived his
first week Newton's father who was also
named Isaac had died three months before
the child was born he had been a
successful farmer and his wife Hannah
was left a financially comfortable Widow
for the next three years she raised
young Isaac alone then in 1646 she
remarried becoming mrs. Barnabas Smith
the relationship between young Isaac and
his stepfather it was a difficult one
and the boys spent a lot of time in the
care of his grandmother Hannah and
Barnabas went on to have three children
together
Benjamin Mary and Hannah Isaac seems to
have gotten on well with his
half-siblings though his relationship
with his mother was tempestuous when he
was 19 Isaac wrote a list of sins for
which he wanted to repent one of them
was threatening to burn down his family
home with his mother and stepfather
inside it isaac attended a village
school sporadically but he didn't begin
his formal schooling until the age of 12
when he enrolled at King's School in
Grant's in England
initially he showed little interest in
his studies and performed poorly in all
subjects however all of a sudden he had
something of an attitude change and he
decided to apply himself more seriously
when he was 17 the Isaac stepfather died
his mother
looking to her oldest son's potential as
the family breadwinner attempted to make
a farmer out of him but Isaac had no
intention of becoming a farmer in fact
he detested the very thought of spending
his life out in the fields unfortunately
after a few months that master at King's
School interceded on Isaac's behalf
convincing Anna that he was best suited
back with them Isaac had been bullied by
another students and chose to respond by
outdoing the bully and his cronies
academically Isaac achieved outstanding
academic results he was the top
performing students of 1660 displaying
an amazing aptitude for all subjects in
June of 1660 one Isaac began studying at
Trinity College at Cambridge University
in order to pay for his studies he
worked outside of his study hours
serving meals and running errands for
his professors the 18 year olds and
entered Trinity with the goal of
becoming a minister of the Church of
England however at some point within
that first year he changed direction it
is unclear why he decided not to pursue
a life in the church but from his later
writings it was clear that he was
forming beliefs about God that were
rather at odds with the doctrine of the
Anglican Church the foundation of the
education that Newton was receiving at
Trinity College was based on the
teachings of Aristotle he was fascinated
with these ideas but objected that many
of the concepts were not based on
evidence that merely on the great
philosophers assumptions and his ideas
Newton became increasingly focused on
the natural sciences as well as
philosophy he studied the works of such
original thinkers as Descartes Kepler
and Galileo because the establishments
had not accepted the scientific findings
of these men Isaac did a lot of his
study outside of the classroom
Newton absorbed a scientific ideas from
wherever he could get them so long as he
was able to test and prove them he would
take these ideas on board and then
debate them with his professors and
fellow students in 1662 newton filled
the pages of a notebook with a list of
45 things he wanted to study they came
under the general heading of physics but
unlike everyone else who had gone before
him Newton didn't just pose the
questions he also set out
he began to devise experiments in order
to find the answers that he was looking
for the following year however Newton's
focus was pulled away from his list of
physics-based questions he became
fascinated with the works of Rene
Descartes and this led him to an
in-depth study of mathematics Descartes
applied the Arabic discipline of algebra
to geometry and called it algebraic
geometry Newton graduated from Trinity
College in August of 1665 he did not
receive that stellar grades that his
talents merited which was probably due
to the fact that he spent so much time
on his own personal studies at this time
all of Europe it was being ravaged by
the bubonic plague in London one in
every four people died colleges were
closed down in an attempt to control the
spread of the disease this postponed
Newton's continued formal education but
he made great use of the time for the
next two years
Isaac focused on his personal studies
from his family home his main areas of
study were calculus Luna motion and
optics he now at the time to mull over
all of the knowledge that he had
accumulated at Cambridge and relate this
to the world around him this led him to
more questions three of the most
fundamental of which were why do things
always fall down why doesn't the moon
fall to earth and why two planets stay
in orbit Newton was convinced the
mathematics would lead to the answers to
these questions he develops a new form
of maths which he called flux eons the
basis of modern day calculus he later
wrote about this time in his life at
this time I was in the prime of my age
of invention and minded mathematics and
philosophy more than any time since
Newton returned to Cambridge in the
spring of 1660 seven he had developed
into a rather peculiar 23 year old man
he was a loner with no friends he was
content to spend hours on ends just with
his thoughts many people dismissed him
as just being an absent-minded recluse
none of his contemporaries had any idea
that he was grappling with an
understanding of planetary motion he
took up a position as a fellow of the
college and held a number of prestigious
positions over the coming years in 1669
Isaac published his first work which was
called analysis by infinite series it
was an investigation of cubic
equations and curves in three dimensions
and was well-received in the wider
scientific community as a fellow of
Cambridge Newton was expected to become
an ordained priest in the Anglican
Church but his opposition's of the
belief in the Trinity doctrine held him
back when he was appointed as Lucasian
Professor of mathematics though college
officials pressed for his ordained ship
he managed to put off the requirements
and he received the promotion now aged
27 Newton held one of the most
prestigious positions in the
mathematical world as an occasion
professor he was required to lecture on
mathematics and place copies of his
notes in the University Library a
requirements which he rarely complied
with
he began lecturing on the subjects of
optics with his notes forming the basis
of his book optics his work on optics
led Newton to focus on improving the
working of the refracting telescope he
was grappling with the problem of how to
get the different colors of light to
come into focus at the same spot on the
lens he failed to solve this issue and
so turned his attention to the
reflecting telescope in 1668 newton
produced the first working reflective
telescope building on the work of
Scottish mathematician James Gregory he
used his telescope to look into the
night sky where he was able to observe
the four moons of the planet Jupiter in
1671 Newton was nominated as a member of
the British Royal Society to support his
proposed candidacy he wrote a letter on
the nature of light which was read at
the Society's next meeting
it caused mixed reactions with some
praising his observation and others
vehemently opposed to it Newton was
admitted to the Royal Society in 1672
marking his entry into the legitimate
scientific community up until then he
had done his work in isolation but now
he was rubbing shoulders with the most
prominent scientists in the world
Isaac immediately came to log ads with
most of the respected members of the
Royal Society Robert Hooke was the
curator of experiments for the Society
unlike the quiet reserve Newton Hooke
was loud and outgoing he objected to
Newton's writings on the nature of light
which challenged the conventional wisdom
over a period of four years Hooke wrote
ten
objections to newton's ideas each of
which were countered by Isaac Newton
hated the constant quarreling which was
a part and parcel of being a member of
the Royal Society and after 15 months he
quit the organization the Secretary of
the Society Henry Oldenburg pleaded with
him to stay assuring him that he was
greatly respected but newton stayed away
from the society for the next two years
[Music]
by 1675 Newton's refusal to take the
priesthood was becoming a serious
problem it was becoming a talking point
which was proving embarrassing to the
college with it looking as if he would
lose his position he turned to his
mentor and former Lucasian Professor
Isaac Barrow for help Barrow suggested
that he write to King Charles the second
and request a special dispensation
allowing him to continue in his position
without entering the priesthood Newton
was generally dissatisfied with the way
that the Anglican Church had evolved his
maintained many of the trappings of the
Catholic Church which he objected to but
his biggest problem was with the
doctrine of the Trinity he could not
accept that God and Jesus were one in
March of 1675 Newton travelled to London
too far for a special dispensation to
his relief and surprise it was granted
without question in fact the king
removed the priesthood requirements for
all future Lucasian Professor ships in
November of 1680 a bright comet appeared
over the skies in England it was tracked
and commented on by the leading
scientists including Newton and a new
Royal Society member named Edmund Halley
in 1684 the two men got together to
discuss the shape of the orbits of
planets Halley was impressed with
Newton's ideas and persuaded him to
present his works in written form to the
Royal Society now just before we get
into the rest of Newton's life I do want
to take a moment to thank the people who
make this video possible and that be
brilliant and I know these mid-roll ads
they're not great for the story here but
these videos are long so I hope you
appreciate our need to have sponsors to
make them possible they're pretty
expensive and time-consuming to produce
now brilliance are a learning platform
which teaches through something called
active learning
unlike biographies which are a nice way
to learn about people's lives like in
Newton learning about science it's a
little bit trickier I don't know if
you've ever had to sit down with a
science textbook I have
and you know this sure a lot of moments
roads like huh well I I don't really
understand what's going on and then you
read it again and you still don't get it
this is passive learning it's no our
brilliance is about brilliance have
active learning and they give you
something super short to read it's
really easy and then you can immediately
apply that to a problem you just rinse
and repeat that and suddenly you're
understanding all sorts of stuff that
you didn't think you would be I've used
brilliance and I think you should go try
it out just to see how fascinating it is
that a complex subject can be grasped
quite so easily obviously with this
biography about Newton they've got lots
of stuff related to what he was up to so
nice tie-in there you could support by
graphics by going to brilliant org
forward slash bhaiyya graphics and let's
get back to Newton for the next 18
months Newton was consumed with the
writing of his masterwork which he
called principia mathematica he was so
absorbed with it that he often neglected
to eat or sleep in this three-volume
work he brought together the results of
20 years of study observation and
thinking about nature he began by laying
out a series of definitions that
underpinned his thoughts on the natural
world these definitions for such things
as inertia matter mass and momentum they
still stand today with his basis
established he then laid out his three
laws of motion the law of inertia or of
acceleration and the law of action and
reaction these in turn led to his most
groundbreaking idea the law of universal
gravitation the law of gravitation it
flew in the face of Aristotle's 2000
year old teaching that the earth
operates under one set of rules while
the Sun the moon planets and stars they
follow different rules according to
Newton there was one law that governs
the motion of everything in the universe
the Principia was presented the Royal
Society in 1686 Robert Hooke immediately
accused Newton of plagiarizing his ideas
despite there's the volume it was well
received when it was published a year
later it became an instant masterpiece
the law of universal gravitation was
accepted as the breakthrough that
explained everything from the motion of
the planets to the tides of the sea
despite the popular reaction to
Principia Newton's ideas they would not
be taught in universities for another 50
years
when he was a student at Cambridge
Newton had first come into contact with
alchemy this pseudoscience had its
origins in the works of Aristotle who
taught that all matter was composed of
four basic elements earth air fire and
water by adjusting the proportions of
any of these components it was believed
that one thing could be turned into
another Aristotle also taught that each
of the elements was connected to a human
emotion or a characteristic Newton was
fascinated with these concepts even
though they were completely at odds with
the rational evidence-based way that he
synthesized his scientific ideas from
that time onwards si led a sort of
double life where he portrayed himself
as the ultimate logical thinker while
pursuing unorthodox alchemists
experiments away from prying eyes at the
same time he also developed a number of
religious views that were decidedly
outside of the mainstream starting in
1669 Newton built up an extensive
library of alchemy related books he was
obsessed with finding universal truth
and saw alchemy as a means of doing so
he wrote thousands of words of notes on
the subjects and conducted hundreds of
experiments his information it was
eventually condensed into a book which
he caught Clavis Newton had a deep and
abiding interest in religion over the
course of his life he wrote more than a
million words on the subjects but very
few of them were actually published
during his lifetime through his studies
of the Hebrew language and careful study
of the Scriptures he became convinced
that modern Christianity was not
following the model that had been set
out by Jesus Newton fundamentally
disagreed with the doctrine of the Holy
Trinity at the time this was act of
heresy punishable by imprisonment or
even worse by writing about it even if
his work was unpublished he was putting
his very life at risk
two important works of scriptural
interpretation that were published in
the century after his death were
observations on the prophecies of daniel
and the apocalypse of Saint John and the
chronology of ancient kingdoms amended
Newton was fascinated with Solomon's
Temple
believing that the building was a
paradigm for the you know
a pattern for the future of the human
race it was his belief that the
architecture of the temple held secrets
to uncovering the mysteries of the
universe and revealed a future Bible
prophecy from it he gave predictions
about the end of the Catholic Church the
return of Christ and the Day of Judgment
in 1687 Newton became involved in a
conflicts between King James the second
and Cambridge University a Benedictine
monk had requested a receipt of a
master's degree without having to swear
oaths and allegiance to the Anglican
Church the monk appealed to the king who
issued a mandate stating that the
university must admit the man without
requiring the oath Newton came out on
behalf of the University and was soon
appointed to represent them at a
commission hearing at Westminster his
arguments proved persuasive and the monk
was not admitted to the University in
January 1689 Newton was elected to
public office when he became the
university's representative in the
convention Parliament with his new
position came a change in personality he
transformed from an introverted retiring
academic to a friendlier more outgoing
public servant in 1690 newton suffers a
period of depression and mental
exhaustion apparently compounded by a
dose of influenza he recovered and spent
the 1690s focused on the moon's orbit
his work required that he obtain
astronomical readings from the first
astronomer royal John Flamsteed that's
the two men they did not get on they
quarreled from the very start with the
relationship eventually completely
breaking down this meant that Newton was
unable to complete his investigation
into lunar cycles in 1696 Newton sought
a higher paying job in the public
service he was awarded the position of
warden of the Royal Mint this job
required a move to London which is where
he actually lived until his death he
oversaw the recoiling of old silver and
gold coins he also standardized the
weight and composition of coins so that
he was able to bring British coinage
much greater degree of accuracy than was
7 own before three years into the job he
was promoted to master of the mint the
job which he held until his death paid
around 1,500 pounds a year
which was a huge amount for the times in
mutant now the most famous scientist in
the land ascended to the presidency of
the Royal Society he held this position
until his death in 1705 he received a
knighthood from Queen Anne however his
acclaim among the scientific community
was strained with an ongoing dispute
with German polymath Gottfried Leibniz
over which of them should get the credit
for the invention of calculus although
Newton was the first to develop the
basic concepts Leibniz published his
work on calculus before Newton the issue
divided the leading scientists of the
time
[Music]
during the last two decades of his life
Newton spent a great deal of time
revising his most famous work principia
mathematica a second edition was
published in 1713 with a third and final
version appearing in 1726
he also indulged a passion for biblical
studies spending days on end compiling
notes on the history of the ancient
Hebrews it is clear that Newton was keen
to ensure his legacy lived on beyond his
physical years he sat for a number of
portraits and sculptures forecast of him
still where he professed an outward
appearance of humility making the
following statement I do not know what I
may appear to the world but to myself I
seem to have been only like a boy
playing on the seashore and diverting
myself in now and then finding a
smoother pebble or a prettier shell than
ordinary whilst the great ocean of truth
lay all undiscovered before me the last
years of newton's life were spent with
his niece catherine barton conduit and
her husband in a 70s he began to suffer
from breathing problems prompting a move
from London to Kensington where the air
was fresher in 1725 at the age of 82 he
was confined to his bed with severe lung
problems coughing fits were constant
since he suffered from an uncontrolled
bladder by early 7027 he seemed to have
recovered somewhat he actually felt good
enough to preside over the Royal Society
meeting on February the 28th but that
effort it was too much for him upon his
return home he was again confined to bed
in early March his doctors diagnosed two
kidney stone and his condition steadily
worsened throughout that month and he
passed away in the early hours of March
the 31st 1727 Newton was awarded the
great honour of being buried at
Westminster Abbey his funeral service
was the most extravagant ever held in
England for a natural philosopher so I
really hope you enjoyed that video if
you did please do give us a thumbs up
below and don't forget to subscribe it
got brand new videos several times a
week if you look at the something else
to watch right now though why not check
out some videos from the archive that
are linked to you on the screen now and
as always thank you for watching
[Music]